welcome back gang this is them hard
[ __ ] feelings
the boys have been away from each other
from a little bit much much pleasantries
sure downstairs like the japanese and
the french meeting yeah had some work to
do
we brought it we had some some packages
delivered we brought these they know
it's koozies are in the koozies are in
and there's a lot of them so get on to
that but usually what happens is i'll be
trying to help and i'll just be in the
way
i'll get that from you that's kevin
james ryan by the way yeah what the [ __ ]
you spend the first 90 seconds [ __ ]
[ __ ] throwing me under the bus
meanwhile
i i just set up the whole recording on
my own you [ __ ] got your finger up
your ass
we'll get to it
funny you mentioned that
why the boss is away you know what i
mean this is the [ __ ] hard feelings
be back in person back in person because
they didn't want that crap i know it was
a little uh
we it was so it's a this is coming up
maybe two days later two or three days
late it's because i was away i was
traveling and then uh
we tried over zoom and
i mean the zooms just aren't good and we
were willing to do the zooms to stay on
schedule for you guys and every i asked
when i posted the one we did everybody's
like [ __ ] no save it for in person
fries ain't the same when you get them
take out baby you know what i mean you
got to eat it in the store and we
appreciate your guys patience with us
yeah and we love that you were like i
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] and also i love the fact that
it's been a couple of days and like on
the on the little message board it's
like you you it's the [ __ ] i'm like
didn't we just [ __ ] go over this
breaking my balls i got enough on my
plate get a venmo get a venom
venmo request for like 285 what they
think one episode of hard feelings
give me 83 cents back kippy i broke i
broke down the numbers and you owe me 70
66.666 repeating ah good stuff happy to
be back man good to see you great to see
you for now rodson that's what i assume
you're thinking no it's great to see you
it's great to see you as well my friend
it's good to be here uh things are good
we're having a good time yeah things are
cooking baby things are cooking squad's
pretty nice yeah that we got we got we
got with us here it's great love them i
[ __ ] love them yeah um
i did have a finger in my ass sure okay
we were jumping right into the [ __ ]
deep end within the last two hours i was
not even i don't even know if it was two
hours i'm fresh
i'm all dirty i went to the bathroom you
could have done it while i was just
there two minutes ago i don't know no
shower or nothing i'm right back on the
street
like a two dollar hooker
so the next john the pick what was the
copay would you have to pay for that bad
boy
they gave me a hundred and a lunch card
give me you got me an uber home get a
pudding down at the cafe damn yeah
that's [ __ ]
it's all right so yeah break it down
what i'll break it down for you so
here's that's too much you go in a
little too deep too much detail for this
kind of stuff here's the story i'm a
real fit piece of [ __ ] yeah any
dingleberries back there what's the db
situation
i felt bad for this guy very dangerous
doc you might want to put on some 3d
glasses or something
you got a wilder's mask back there chief
huh
burn your eyes out it's like getting
lasik when you look at this thing it's
like an eclipse
i'll pat you up for a couple of days get
you a german shepherd in a dead cup hey
no coming back from this huh
he's got welder's eye from your [ __ ]
what do they call that like sparky eye
or well welder's high
yeah it's like plumber's butt it's the
same thing
like plumber's butt but way worse
[Laughter]
so as you know
the gang knows um you're getting some
checkups getting some [ __ ] tune-ups
yeah i don't know when this insurance is
going to run out or you know what's
going to happen so i'm getting mind
while the guest should
like any upstanding citizen
try to fleece a big corporation before
they realize what's happening
this chaos is 40 grand
oh well he's dead now
um he can't so yeah he can't stick your
finger up a dead man's [ __ ]
got you doc later we might have to turn
the air on dude i'm dying
getting pretty hot on these flights
honestly
um so as everybody knows you know what i
mean i've been going to get my checkups
done it's been really slow going sure
you know um it's just a pain in the ass
to [ __ ]
literally
i mean i mean the insurance company you
know they have outdated information um
you know oh well there's a there's a
dermatologist here and then you go there
he's not taking patience oh nightmare
yeah yeah yeah
it takes a while it's real [ __ ] bozo
[ __ ] it takes a while but what i've
realized is a lot of people they call
hey i need an appointment uh for
whatever and then the woman on the phone
or man on the phone says
uh okay the next availability for you
know for it's going to be three months
from now and they're like oh no forget
it you just keep it just keep it oh it
goes by quick of course
you always think i'm going to get
somebody with like tomorrow and you're
like that ain't going to [ __ ] happen
because it's all just checking the box
get getting rid of it yeah um so today
was the urologist
all right i went to see the urologist
i'm 40 from a 45 year old man um and
they recently recommended that if you
you you got the old prostrate back there
you want to get it checked out of 45.
sure used to be 50.
now it's 45. yeah i think the doctors
are just getting younger and they like
the party a little bit yeah yeah
you know these new kids
it's all anal with these guys with these
[ __ ] millennials that's what's all
that is still a virgin technically right
in the butt um
so yeah i went in now i don't think your
butt is virgin-esque i think there might
there's there's there's been do you mean
like look wise no
i mean entry-wise oh yeah oh yeah we'll
get into that um
but it's it's like an old dirt track
it's nice
the skin's always a little tougher now
that's what's bad i hate that that's
what i thought that was my biggest fear
for him i wasn't gonna look pretty back
there you know what i mean yeah cause
there's like there's rings you know what
i mean i've been to the center of the
earth and i
i've been to the franchise
i've been to the crossroads
and i miss my uncle charles y'all
go down there to sell your soul huh
give me a fully's button
too come heavy
um yeah it's real sloppy back there it's
bad just the way it went that's the one
thing i wish i had i wish i had a nice
ass like you know what i mean yeah let's
start on other things i mean you wish
you had a nice dance i wish you were 220
pounds but hey you know what i mean
um wishing one-hand [ __ ] in the other
see what fills up first but no yeah
that's pretty good
that's too focused on my anal experience
it's jumping up over there
going through the rolodex down memory
lane i apologize
i stepped out first hey doc can you put
a wig on and call yourself susie
keep the mustache though
oh man
um yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean
like i've dabbled around back there in
my life and you know i've had fingers in
there when i was younger i remember they
gave me one in the er because yeah was
this in the shed what's happening
was hospital handwritten
um and that that wasn't fun this was
smooth that wasn't fun like it hurt like
you know that because
there's all right yeah that's gonna say
there's pain and then there's that
rubber band
burning searing butthole pain okay which
did not happen this time sure smooth as
silky yeah you got a couple more miles
on here two-car garage back there
park a boat in there if you wanted to
talk bring the family we got plenty of
room
um but i went in there got a boston
whaler back there
some scuba gear
all right i know what he's doing
tighten it up
any kid's gonna get we get a little
loopy when we haven't seen each other in
a couple of days
i'm all jacked up on [ __ ] finger butt
i don't know what you're talking about
i'm pumped i feel feel sexy
uh well
you're not i hate to break it to you
so i naively i took a shower i got all
freshened up ready to go but i don't
really wear a lot of underwear these
days and i didn't think about that right
yeah i didn't think about that until i
was already out the door because i
thought
you know the way they would work it is
you go in you get a consultation and
it's like okay
come back in a week and you know you
have to do this this and this you know
fast overnight or something like that
don't eat anything because i cuz i got
another little tidbit to this without
getting too graphic
there's been a lot of traffic lately
in my neighborhood down hey man your
[ __ ] i didn't know you no that's what
i mean yeah i mean my butthole oh it
hasn't been it hasn't been good yeah
it's been jammed off run yeah wait
you've been the snacks are different now
and i think the snacks are getting to me
if i have like a handful of those peanut
butter pretzels at night i feel like the
peanut butter weighs me down i think
you're supposed to be eating better
you're doing peanut butter pretzels is a
snack protein it's okay
yeah it's all right
we're not gonna get into this we'll
sidestep that fairness is great point
being that i'm a little i'm you know
things are tight tight nothing was doing
the last couple of days
so i took some steps to alleviate
shotgun falls after that fingers in
there clear the blockage
be ripping and roaring got a
ten-year-old coming out like the state
troopers showed up and started moving
and sort of directed traffic
oh god
um
took some metamucil took a stool
softener stuff like that you know what i
mean ate real cleaner last couple days
but i forgot that it was [ __ ] today
so i was half worried that because when
he went up there i felt like uh i got a
poop you know what i mean what's all the
muscles are being [ __ ] dude when he
when he was about to pull that out i
thought it was
gonna be messy then it's gonna be like a
gallagher show
nurse practitioner in the front row
front row at sea world um but it wasn't
said it felt said it felt fine took my
blood had a pee in a cup
um that was it young good looking dude i
felt real bad for him
i was like how do we and he did happen
so quick i was like he was like alright
so normally we would do was this that
and the other thing he said and i think
he was looking for a way out
yeah i mean because he was like we'll do
the blood we'll do the urine he's like
if you want we can do the do the rectal
you know i maybe was going to launch
this thing
shower for nothing doc let's go
you take me out it don't come on the lot
unless you're going to buy as h foley
would say so let's go
you can keep your pants on if you pump a
miner coming off i got my special undies
on doc what do you mean
uh so that was it man in and out yeah
and literally sure felt good i mean
they're not gonna hang around in there
no now i apologized after it was over
and i figured since you know i mean i've
been around the horror game a little bit
you know what i mean after the deed's
done you know the real people come out
so i just wanted to make sure i was like
yeah there wasn't a bunch of [ __ ] on
your finger was there he was like nah
you're good i was like okay i just
wanted to check because i would have
felt bad yeah but that's like a you
thing too you're like everything's okay
right please like me don't dislike me
every yeah you had a good time right
everything's okay please please please
tell me what i want to hear absolutely
you can just tell foley what he wants to
hear yeah that's what everybody should
start doing no things would be a lot
easier
everybody just does what i ask
all right just lie to me like i lied to
myself yeah goddammit [ __ ] let's go what
are we doing here
stop with it come on someone's got to
give in [ __ ] going around in circles
just lie to me guys let's go
it also it took well it did take me 10
years to realize just to not even
bring you into things bring you into
i do decisions you still don't and you
still don't you still don't give it to
me right away when you should sometimes
it takes a little longer we gotta you
like to dance a little bit sometimes
like hey
what a pale moonlighter you like to go a
couple rounds of crazy a buddy i've
never i've never came on this program
and
[Laughter]
and said i wasn't nuts
i'm nuts i like to i like to it's not
one piece of paper out there that says i
ever said that i ain't [ __ ] crazy
i'll tell you it's that right now listen
i'm an older guy i don't [ __ ] you
know every time i hung up the gloves but
every now and then i like to spar you
know what i mean stay sharp man in case
i'm in the street and something comes
out i still gotta have my hands on me
the gloves yeah those [ __ ] yeah catch
these [ __ ] hands
the older you get though you're like
yeah whatever yeah yeah yeah keep it
moving
put the baseball game on and shut up
it really is man and it's so funny too
cause like
my perspective you're you were my age
now when i met you
i've known you for ten years
wait hold on i was your age yeah now
when i frequency him
i don't like those movies what movies is
that one
the dirty ones
i share a little mermaid and almost
puked ew we kissed her
and that priest catches the [ __ ]
woody i remember that when i was seeing
that when you were 10. who the priest in
little mermaid see that's you know
what's funny is
uh i was watching uh the documentary on
woodstock 99. all right there is a
difference between your generation and
mine okay and it was that was very clear
220 pounds
i don't know how that's necessary they
were giving us milk and [ __ ] at lunch
what do you want yeah we had milk too i
just kept at the one
i got a huge carton
the calf gallon
oh are those trash
what the the paper ones the half gallon
and the little cup and the little jaws
that we get at lunch the ones that are
the the containers the cartons yeah
cartons
cartons i mean technology i mean i mean
you know liquid uh
containers technology has come a long
way sure 70s 80s since the car and since
the carton yeah
what's tough on the carton is if you
don't get a good open and then it's got
like you kind of oh you're [ __ ] and
it's like and then you ever have to open
the whole thing
yeah and it's kind of like well i
remember i don't drink the milk out of
it when it's when the whole thing's open
what that was that'd be it oh no you
open the back end
pop the trunk on the thing no way
blow the
[ __ ] start in the multiverse no never
never pop the trunk on a [ __ ] garden
of milk
don't [ __ ] div you do i ain't coming
over
i ain't staying for breakfast whatever
you cut it off yeah gentlemen uh i
remember the tech the technology that
dropped for me that as a kid was like
this guy's got a little bit of cash if i
was at someone's house
was the container or the carton
but it had the circle spout oh
you go over to someone's house they got
the tropic gotta pull the pin
out the nature's finest or whatever it
was called oh
i remember being over a couple of
sleepovers and [ __ ] you know mrs
jones pulling that thing out i started
housing let me see some w2s what's going
on here how many what you guys what you
guys net last year this broad knows how
to run a breakfast table let me tell you
that don't [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
charging for this mrs m
holy [ __ ]
but what i was gonna say is that the
biggest difference um the music and
stuff like that and watching that
documentary did you watch that
documentary about woodstock just about
how like you know the music got real
angry for some reason sure
um
but the cartoons i think is what the big
is different what what stretches us out
all right the like the things that were
hot when you were when you were a kid
and i really missed
uh lion king which is big with you guys
sure little mermaid
yeah for the girl i mean like yeah that
was like a girls from for like my age
that was a girl's movie i gotcha i
gotcha but you know i watched we watched
it for the boner sure sure but you get
what i'm saying
i watch other movies for the boners too
all right
man if you're in the cartoon porn
go see somebody hannah or an audi porn
or whatever
this is great it's
[ __ ]
the tentacle i don't know what's going
on
somebody give me a real estate agent and
a milf will you um please i know right
[ __ ] meat and potatoes guy over here
you're just doing my [ __ ] porn bit by
the way wait what that's literally my
[ __ ] porn [ __ ] i thought it was the
the different languages
i know but i don't watch your act what
are you talking about i say i'm an old
school guy more meat and potatoes i'm
gonna give me a [ __ ] pool boy or
whatever oh that was it then i'd like to
credit kevin
one of the writers on the show here
he's a good kid
just doing my [ __ ] stand-up bits he
won the ayg page program
uh i apologize that's not the most
age-bully thing
to rep purely by accident yeah linear
thinking as they would say or you just
heard my bit 50 000 times and did it to
me seeped into the concrete
anyway i apologize
um no need to apologize buddy we're
doing a comedy podcast so yeah that was
uh that was the point i don't know where
we left off
i started talking about that cartoon
point i got a little distracted i gotta
be honest with you i don't know what you
were saying before i tried to make the
point about little mermaid i know either
do i it's a couple it's a couple streets
oh oh no no i remember you're my age now
yeah there we go
we both missed our we both don't
remember our points on it but that was
the original scenario broadcaster here
brought us right back um
and i now
realize
the things that i would get frustrated
with you
about a little bit meaning what just
like i'm not the same as you when you
were my age i was a needle going the
other way what do you mean you're you're
doing okay now i'm doing great now so
are you because of it
no um
uh
no i'm just saying i think in like the
in certain
i
i don't know how to put this i would
watch you do stuff and me my perspective
as like a 25 year old i'm like this
guy's
i don't even know but now i just find
myself like appreciating little things i
remember being 25 years
on [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um
no i don't know just like certain things
i'm appreciating
the slower
buddy easier but as a 25 year old i
didn't understand it but give me an
example
i'm trying to think walking
because i know what you mean and i i'm
just trying to think of like you know
i think now as i get all i have the
appreciation of like i'm
even like last night i got a slice of
cecilia when i got back to the states
okay and it was just like this like
i don't know just like a moment of la
and every every i would remember
watching you do stuff i'd be staring at
you like a [ __ ] like a caged animal
i'm taking doing research i'm taking no
i'm like [ __ ]
jane apathy who was who's the late who's
the boost of dumb bro to live with the
the apes
i'm like kippy goodall over here [ __ ]
watching you eat a cupcake
he was accepted into the tribe
[Laughter]
all i had
i keep walking up and handing you dead
mice
we got to get into that by the way
we got an update
um having something your apartment oh
you were away you come back we'll get
into it after um
but i just like appreciate like this
slowing down at times
i go like oh yeah i'll just [ __ ]
before and i i do have the mentality do
have that anxiety that's kind of you
know what helped
uh us
build this is like my [ __ ]
sure my motor [ __ ] never shuts off
but now i'm going i when i do find like
i can enjoy i used to eat pizza it's
like a fries
but now i'm like oh let's take a [ __ ]
minute even if you don't do this but
it's like you set it there and you have
it set a little salt and pepper maybe or
whatever you just the process of like oh
i'm gonna take these next six minutes
before it'd be like i'd shove it down my
[ __ ] mouth one on my [ __ ] and keep
it [ __ ] moving yeah it's nice um but
i find myself i go like oh that was like
a foleyism and i think it's just as you
get as now i'm older buddy you're
wearing my shirts i don't know what i'm
slowing down a little kid's a big fan
i i that's all i might and i 100 what
you mean and now
you're like 35 [ __ ] so i'm 45. think
about where i'm at i'm 34 still my
birthday's this week by the way what are
you getting the kip oh [ __ ] you gotta
get yourself dumped i mean i'm sending
you [ __ ] gwop every month okay
how about a nice ayt cousin
fun for the family paid for that
i guess if i paid for them out of my
um
[Music]
i'm gonna get you something
100 percent
what size are you
what are we talking about in the bedroom
um i get you a small dildo to build your
confidence
what come on i didn't fully understand
it to be honest fair enough what i was
gonna say is if you're if you're 34 okay
i'm 45 think about where i'm at and i i
do that's the other perspective i'm like
i'm gonna be sleeping all the time i got
two words for you baseball because it's
fantastic when you want to [ __ ] shut
down the studio slow game the [ __ ]
pitcher they take their time the batter
takes their time everybody they're
focused they're [ __ ] this they're
that it's been me and baseball have hit
such a [ __ ] perfect crossroads in our
lives that i don't know what to tell you
i got the mlb package all right 100
bucks for the year watch every [ __ ]
game phillies are cooking
i didn't do anything while you were gone
just so you know i watched baseball for
a week and a half it was a vacation i
also don't want me going away to be
viewed as my vacation that was our
vacation sure yeah of course yeah yeah i
was [ __ ]
loved it it's nice i'm going on vacation
again this week by the way
that's a real vacation more baseball
play ball doing doubleheaders in split
two
what is it what a beautiful day for a
ball game how about two or so that's
exactly right my friend
uh who cares
um
so
i
i was
away i have some some stuff from over
there and this is a little bit what do
you mean you pay for them out of your
own thing why didn't you use the card
there was no money in the card what yeah
yikes
well we had a book
no we had to buy a bunch of [ __ ]
knock over the mic and run out the door
trying to catch me fatty that's a 747
waiting outside i throw a baseball that
way
uh
i mean i don't want to get into the
finances of course no we have a lot of
road stuff coming up we had to buy a
[ __ ] bunch of plane tickets buy a
bunch of [ __ ]
airbnb like you know it's
well you go ahead and take that you go
ahead straighten yourself out you're a
good kid thanks all right yeah send me a
receipt send me an invoice you're
staring at the [ __ ] boxes what do you
mean i don't know what's in there
it could be all bananas it's all it's
all dupes for me
10-year supply of propecia
which by the way i've been getting
compliments so someone goes
kippy's got a nice head of lettuce which
i [ __ ] love
so
it's got a sleeve of romaine up there
make me a caesar uh is it coming back it
is yeah yeah i know for sure it's coming
back
it doesn't come back it just fills out a
little bit it just fills out well this
is what's weird to me and now i'm
sweating profusely and when it gets wet
it is a tough look do the dishes with
that
[Laughter]
it's like here's the thing for me
i like it
okay like what the i like
like the bruce willis look of course
okay like i said i'm if i
and it sounds so weird like i don't it
doesn't bother me no of course not but
listen here's the thing so i like the
bruce willis look now when i'm with you
okay whether it's five years ago or now
that's the most bruce willis look that
you have
all right but then as you start to lose
it a little more i continue to like the
you know what i mean so when i look at
those old pictures of you
it's like looking at you from like the
show you were on in the 90s wait like
it's like wait what picture it's like
like from pictures like when i started
stand up just from a year two years ago
three years ago four years ago whenever
i see older pictures of you it's like
when you don't like when by the way tony
soprano aged from season one to the last
season okay but you think he stayed the
same and then you see a side by side
yeah and you're like oh and you always
liked the newer one better because
you're more accustomed to i'm more
accustomed to it because what have you
done for me lately yeah because it's
weird you look at an old picture of you
it's like filled in a little more and
it's like darker yeah yeah you look
weird it looks weird to me yeah no i
know i see um you look like a guy in
like nypd blue that only lasted a couple
of seasons or something they killed me
um favorite actor
i figured i was going to say if we're
going to go i forgot about that what
[ __ ] kid shooting national ads
you yeah yeah for what a company that
doesn't make any sense right it's
something it's a shell corporation or
something you're just sitting up to be
the fall guy
hey bring them in here have them sign
these papers
um i think that would be a chicken
sandwich situation
yeah i don't say any names or anything
just don't say the name of the company
no but i mean they'll see it when it
comes don't know the name of the company
i'm gonna let that happen all right yeah
it's a pretty pretty big company i've
never heard of it so let's go on record
i mean i'm a pretty smart guy right i'm
pretty well i'm pretty well rounded
pretty cultured
hi i'm a trolley from david's
automobiles yeah right
um
crazy shoot
crazy shoot good time it was out
speaking of this oh you did it did it
did it we've been checked out we haven't
been talking hey you do i mean you're on
vidcon we're still working baby
someone's got to keep the lights on
watching [ __ ] baseball also do i get
a cut of this got to have contact do i
get a cut of this you got a little
tribute coming your way you have to you
got to pay off that envelope better not
be light at the end of the month listen
i got a promo code for you okay i don't
know what to tell you get on there i'll
give you 10 off it foley's roofing
inside
um
yeah cool shoot i don't really have much
about it but it was in uh it was shot in
saturday top-notch broadcast
we shot in saddle river new jersey very
sopranos we were in like a sopranos
mansion type thing okay um and uh
yeah it was cool it's like financial
services or something financial services
i play the idiot you know no really yeah
you should have saw the guy that was a
spokesman talk about going against the
great
dude that was a spokesman older salt and
pepper hair beard [ __ ] in shape sharp
and just comes out make sure that you
don't act like you know just does the
whole thing dude he did it like eight
times sell reverse mortgages oh perfect
every [ __ ] time it was awesome and
then i play the fat more on doing the
thing that you're not supposed to do
yeah which is gambling your finance your
family's financial future away however
all right
not people in this room sure but some
people out there think the kid's pretty
talented
all right i think you're very talented
we had this conversation two weeks ago
thank you i appreciate that now we're
doing our thing i know yeah i didn't
know you brought your fishing rod
[ __ ] compliments
it's been a while i've had a bald marlin
on the line here
i've been given bad performances at the
apartment all week i need i need the
positivity yeah
um
director loved it clients were there you
know i'm not really a commercial guy you
know what i mean the first one that i
did the the client wasn't there client's
there so there's some [ __ ] there's
some [ __ ] production in this sure
some coin there's some ghee in this
thing yeah um production people are in
like another room they hardly ever come
out or the uh
the the developer the people in
development at the company the clients
as they call them um the people that are
like don't do this don't do that because
they get to put their two cents in and
they have a specific i don't know why
clients we get it okay then do you call
them clients right and then we went on a
forum i'm all jacked up on mountain dew
here buddy i don't know what to tell you
i'm excited i apologize no i know but
i'm just saying i'm changing my story
you're explaining the word clients to me
like i'm like i got opioids running down
my face it's like it's an uber pool i'm
in the front seat this guy's still in my
bed
um
the clients yes people who are in the
company and the production company has a
specific producer that just goes back
and forth and like you know they'll
watch it take and then he'll come out
how can he do it and then the director
you know they're all work together and
stuff like that director was [ __ ]
awesome guys been doing it for a long
time again older guy thin good-looking
[ __ ] wearing like cool like uh like
la shorts la shirt [ __ ] cool like
surfer hat what's up what are what are
la shorts to you what those board shorts
that they wear out there
the production the producer this thing
was wearing board shorts the
the director was the directors are
important they were la guys it was like
100 degrees board shirt portraits are a
bathing suit this guy wasn't in a
bathing suit no he wasn't in a bathing
suit um he was in penguin shorts that
that penguin he had a nice pair of
penguin shorts shorts okay i thought
they were board shorts okay i don't know
what's going on
when it comes to that kind of stuff sure
but he was super cool
um
end of the day
they go shoot me at shoot me a text or
talk to you mm-hmm say all right shoot
him attacks
get me coke
i'm only in town for two nights i don't
know anybody in saddlebrook can you get
him can you get me can you give me a can
you get me an eight ball hey fat ass you
look at your party
that's good screw it around yeah um
no they said that uh
the client really dug me mm-hmm and that
he pitched to them that they should make
it kind of an ongoing thing oh i could
do it like yeah oh great
thing i'm definitely wet my beak on that
so we'll see if that happens you know
that's great a lot of things gonna fall
into place for that but it was nice yeah
yeah it was a nice day yeah you know
that's awesome yeah congratulations
thank you happy for you out of my
[ __ ] hair
what's left of it
i'm starting to podcast with this guy
can you get beer coozies
um but that's it other than that little
baseball saw the fam
yeah that's kind of you know where you
know where i was at what's good started
doing overnight oats big fan you just
eat them overnight
stop sleeping i just eat oats all night
[Laughter]
doing overnight pizzas guys
like a gelding out there grubbing them a
gelding gelding horse it was a horse
horse joke
yeah wait wait right we're right uh okay
i uh
got a little bit a little bit on a trip
over there yeah you know last i checked
in was the ayg
we talked about the pool those [ __ ]
germans swimming in the pool yeah yeah
i'd rather hear where are we at i'd
rather hear about the apartment here and
then save the germany for the next one
kippy's kippy's kippy's vacation okay
you got to have some mileage out of that
sure okay you know yeah for sure tell me
what happened with the mice so this was
on my mind a lot so i'm trying to think
because our recording schedule was
[ __ ] bonkers for me to get out of
town because it's like we already we do
four episodes a week between itunes and
patreon
so it's like and then
hey kevin once you get here what am i a
jerk off i know what we do that's idiot
financial folks
um
no so i'm saying our recording schedule
is you know pretty our production
schedule is pretty
uh rigorous to begin with and then if
i'm leaving for 10 days we have to make
those up so it's like we're working
double time to take time off sure
um and plus we had the wedding so that
we lost another day production
so
it's just it was very hectic
the mice problem like i said
it was getting worse i was seeing them
it was getting worse i told you like i
saw them in the kitchen we talked about
this i know i know we talked about this
to the point i didn't know it was
getting it was getting worse from when
we talked about it
no it was like it was to the point where
i go oh this is a [ __ ] issue it's not
just you told me you just saw one run
across when you were on the laptop that
was the story i got
so it's worse than you said so then
maybe okay so then maybe i got home
i saw one because my wife was so it must
have been after we recorded i get home i
see one during the day because the
apartment was probably heard you're
talking [ __ ] yeah it's like bringing him
coming his coming back with his boys i
saw another one i think it was the day
we were the day before we were leaving
the night something that's a tough look
i know now i'm hemmed up getting on that
plane knowing these guys are in your
apartment we gotta leave in the morning
it's now like eight o'clock or something
at night you put them onions away
because they'll get into them eventually
so this is so it's like eight o'clock at
night [ __ ] hardware stores closed
i can't and the brawl's gonna build up a
treehouse no we're gonna get [ __ ]
traps
and then a couple of big boys the lady's
like
uh i think i said she wants to do the
humane traps who oh right so she's like
i want to do the humane trap and we told
we did talk about this i'm like i'll
[ __ ] glue trap them and then [ __ ]
put them in the toilet or throw them out
the window i don't care
um the humanes they don't hurt them it's
going there and they go in there and
then it's in like a little tube and then
they're in there and then you go and
like take it out of the woods yeah and
leave it where we're [ __ ] we're in
the elevator whatever
yeah um
so now i'm going to get the glue traps
let's [ __ ] we cuz in my head i go
this is a [ __ ] issue i'm leaving for
[ __ ] 10 days that listen that's what
i mean rats you're freaking out roaches
you're freaking out mice you're [ __ ]
taking it but you're leaving i'm going i
just come back
you're leaving for 10 days that's what
darkness no movement [ __ ] whatever's
there they're gonna get into it they got
full run and let me tell you something
those little [ __ ] get comfortable
real [ __ ] quick yeah that's why you
gotta keep the lights on and bang some
pots and pans keep on i'm telling you
cause when it gets quiet that's when
[ __ ] the activity starts so like the
viet cong sneaking around at night yeah
yeah
so i can't use the the lethal track and
i'm doing this just to appease her
otherwise i'd be like let's [ __ ]
[ __ ] call in the air strikes i don't
[ __ ] care let's [ __ ] napalm this
thing you got that 101 in there
i don't know what that is i'm getting
airborne i'm thinking like exterminate
or something um so i'm like uh let's
[ __ ]
so i'm like all right but wait but i'm
like well we can't get we can't buy them
because it's too too late like the
supermarket doesn't sell them they just
sell the [ __ ] that [ __ ] did you have
some glueys at the house no but they can
get them at the [ __ ] market so i went
to the mall and she goes yeah well let's
see uh her friend who lives in the
building i think i told you they had
them and then got rid of them and i'm
pretty sure they just pushed him into my
[ __ ] apartment sounds like it so
uh they're like she has the humidity
these are the people with the baby
yeah they do have a baby they're not the
ones that were yelling at you about the
noise no no no no
they definitely that's def that's a
whack job no yeah no no um this is uh
that's cold war [ __ ] yeah
right yeah yeah like we [ __ ] up the
coffee fields in cuba with the insects
yeah that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] mcmahon i don't know what
we're talking about i'm sorry jesus
[ __ ] christ would you watch the
history channel when you weren't
watching baseball what the [ __ ]
mcnamara's [ __ ]
they're in the cold war you dropped it
like that was a dr dre album during the
cold war we released some kind of bug in
the
healthy fields in cuba to destroy the
crop gotcha so that's what i'm saying
they're doing downstairs
the long train to nowhere
next stop holyfield
i haven't been there in a while or
you've been there the whole time i've
been gone
you just don't know it like hotel
california
um
[Music]
so she gets the
traps from her and i might have covered
some of this i don't know where we're
staying no because this was the night we
were leaving you didn't this was the
night we were leaving it's all free
i'm loving this i saw one and i'm like i
gotta [ __ ] we gotta act because it's
not just like i saw one last night you
leave that place for 10 days you come
back you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ]
that's what i'm that's my dude now i'm
going listen if they don't have them i'm
glue trapping the whole [ __ ]
apartment i'm i'm i'm literally gonna
cover the whole [ __ ] floor we're
talking growing breeding [ __ ] everywhere
so you'll come back to a [ __ ] army so
now i'm worried so we set the [ __ ]
humane traps
the first night right then we're leaving
the next day at like noon or 10 or
something i forget all right so you'll
steal yo i'll i'll be able to check in
the morning but it's like you never
catch them the first night they're
they're crafty they know that yeah yeah
they're not [ __ ] bozos you know what
i mean they made it to they made it to
the sixth floor somehow yeah so
you don't get your own apartment you
don't get your own apartment in
manhattan by being an idiot i mean
you're doing something right no that's
why you don't know something that's like
you don't have an apartment in manhattan
um
so
i'm [ __ ] i check in the morning
nothing so now i'm like johnny on the
spot now i have that anxiety [ __ ] i
gotta get it to the airport blah blah
blah you gotta make sure the paperwork
travel international the vaccine card
the dad the whole [ __ ] nine you know
um
so
we uh i'm all i'm worried about that
wake up in the morning nothing
so i text the so my
my wife texts her friend hey we're
leaving can we leave you a key and you
can pop in and check to see if we got
any like in the next couple of days you
know check in like two days or whatever
i was gonna water the plants and [ __ ]
like that
um
i'd hide my underwear uh
i can't have them rooting around put it
in the freezer
so like there
where that morning that night we get rid
of i get rid of anything they could
[ __ ] eat i like dude i empty out the
fridge i don't know how strong these
[ __ ] i don't know what i do
everything i'm [ __ ] throwing we i
like literally remove all
possible food sources okay right
and then like i'm wary 2 like you know
i'm checking in the cabinets and the
drawers and stuff where we have like
whatever like spices or flour or
something
all still intact no you know kind of
like chew through or whatever you see
the paper and the droppings nothing so
i'm like well they're not in there
they're not in there i don't know really
what they're eating i don't know what
they're i don't know what they're doing
um
so i'm [ __ ] nervous so the two days
so we get over there two days goes by no
you didn't you didn't
bend and put down some glues you're just
i didn't i did how many how many how
many humane traps you got four got four
i put them where i've seen them okay
right i put one
i put one in the family room yep i lost
a war you got it
two in the kitchen one in the hallway
okay all where they've been all where
we've had [ __ ] eyes on them gotcha
you did what you could
that's what i'm it's a [ __ ] last act
of a desperate man to try to retake the
this is the alamo i'm going i get one
move here and then i'm out you know if
you stripped a place with glowy's you'd
probably come back
and i wouldn't have to kill them either
they would be over yeah yeah so wow then
so
a couple days goes by what you come back
and one's still alive that's the one
that's going to get you oh yeah he's
only gotten stronger and more man that's
the john wick of the group
killed my dog sharpen a mustang around
your apartment
so
we uh
two days whatever couple days goes by in
germany i go oh hey text uh you know
text your friend find out
any update
she's like nothing like nothing didn't
respond no responded no nobody's there
no mice okay i went home they're not
falling dude they're not going in there
i know what do we do the glue traps it's
a matter of [ __ ] up
you know what i mean like all you have
to do is you get we get caught in them
oh yeah yeah i mean you kept one on your
shoe those things you have to you know
you're you're tricking the mouse into
going in there they're just they're just
running over it not realizing they're
going oh this smells good and then
they'd probably go in there and add it
there they're probably [ __ ] renting
that place out there
of course and i knew it wasn't gonna
work you gotta play tough but these
aren't like country bumpkin mice cause
you gotta because this ain't a [ __ ]
field mouse everything evolves mice have
been around for how long think about new
york city mice dude yeah come on taking
the subway early [ __ ] being exposed
all this stuff they're [ __ ] on they
know what's going on i know so that's
what and i'm going i know there's no
real hope of [ __ ] catching one of
these things in the [ __ ]
so
uh she goes nothing a couple days later
nothing now i'm [ __ ] i'm like these
things just have the run of the [ __ ]
roosters did she did did you ask her to
check to see if there's any poop or
anything in here yeah she said no
the first time i got no sign of anything
and then you know whatever and also it's
too like i'm distracted we're busy i got
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on halfway through
the week she goes radio silent yeah the
mouse get her
she's been taken
she can't come to the phone right now
so
we uh
we're [ __ ] it's nothing so i'm now
i'm nervous i'm proper shocked that of
what i'm gonna open the door to do that
picture i'm gonna open the door to like
a [ __ ] frat party you know they're
gonna be doing keg stands and [ __ ] i'm
thinking it's gonna be a [ __ ] scene
um
and dude so i opened that door and it's
like
you're nervous i'm literally genuinely
nervous i'm like do i have to take my
[ __ ] house back and plus no i'm super
[ __ ] jet-lagged i got work to do it's
an episode night i got to get the
[ __ ] episode up and plus i was going
out last night to meet up with some
friends so i'm like i'm hemmed up
time-wise here if this is an issue i
don't really have a lot to deal with can
i say this that walking back in after
being away for a while especially in the
summer it's like that heat in there
stuck heat oh you got to hit the ac
takes a good hour to get that the energy
in there right it's still not right it's
still a little off plus she's not there
so it's like
just like the vibe isn't this
everything's just a little off it's
weird all right sucks yeah in august too
it's tough he's like a little kid that's
weird it's weird i heard a noise earlier
today and [ __ ] yeah i was just like you
didn't hear that dude just it sounded
like someone
or something and i'm like
nope that did not i don't even see that
you know
don't you put that on me
um one of our guys hit one of our
listeners hit us up about uh about that
too let's stop i don't know what you're
talking about told me a story okay we'll
keep it too you don't want to do it keep
it to you and him it's scary stop it
stop
i'll pull the plug in this whole
operation
um i uh
come so i not so i checked the traps
right away nothing in the traps
i'm like yeah of course of course this
[ __ ] humane [ __ ] i gotta catch
the you know these they're not they're
not [ __ ]
idiots so i go all right so i search
everything and before i left i checked
the closets to make sure they're not
[ __ ] like nesting in there or
something you know what i mean like in
an old [ __ ] sweater or something or
like a cardboard box that's what they do
they have babies and [ __ ] so before i
left i [ __ ]
the two walk-in closets got all you know
everything off the ground check swept no
signs no nothing so i'm like i don't
they're not lit i'm going they're not
living in my [ __ ] i don't know where
they are i think they're passing through
so i come back the only sign of them
was
four droppings on the stove
great and i go
that so now this is i would love to hear
your input my input is like that's where
the holes are there's holes in there
into the walls sure like from like the
you know from the gas line of course but
i'm going
and so there's now for ten days there
was no food no trash no food no new
smells there could be some little [ __ ]
underneath that stove
yeah
piece of this i'm also going yeah of
course i'm also going i don't think
i think they might have
packed bags and kicked rocks
after a couple of days because there's
nothing going on maybe there's no new
food because if there was there would be
more mouth [ __ ] i feel i agree for four
little droppings over 10 11 days of
nobody there they would have
they'd be [ __ ] everywhere i feel no
i don't know what no water no water been
completely [ __ ] dry
no trash no not even like a p nothing
they can get their [ __ ]
dirty little paws on so i think
i might be in the clear but
i guess you'll find out won't you we're
going we're on the road this week we're
in rhode island in boston uh
i'm gonna glue trap them when i leave
she ain't around shane around what she
don't know won't hurt her you know what
i mean while she's on vacation he can do
what he wants never asked me about my
business yes hey listen we when we were
fighting together i fought your way now
you're gone it's kippy rules and kippy
plays by his own [ __ ] book okay
gotta you got a family to protect
i gotta take my [ __ ] apartment back
so i'm gonna glue trap it and then this
week and i go to the dominican republic
for four days five days [ __ ] glue
trap and then too hopefully i come back
and they're all [ __ ] stuck and one
last one i [ __ ] mush them
yeah holy [ __ ] so
uh yeah tense tense it's tense man and
it's like then it's in your head and my
uh while we were you know
we'll do the
jeremy stuff next but i was talking
about i was talking about my
mother-in-law it's so weird to say my
mother-in-law
um
talk to her like that what like just
natural nice conversations
what else would i talk to her about
she's speaking
uh yeah her english is really good okay
a certain just like vocab that like
things you know like what the how how
would you say when's the last time you
were there and
wait wait till next sunday yeah um but
she was like she was telling and it
freaked me the [ __ ] out and now i can't
[ __ ] i've been
she's like we had them in like the 90s
or something european mice yeah they'll
wear beret
they're all circumcised i don't like
that's how the plague started what
european mice it wasn't mice t-bone was
just saying this it was rats gerbils or
something
guinea pig i don't know what the
whatever hey they're all rats to me okay
whatever you do on the weekend
she said she was all right
i don't care if you give it a name or
not and put it in some [ __ ] wood
chips that thing's a rat
anything's more than a golden retriever
completing the size of a beagle i'm
putting a [ __ ] glue trap down okay
what about chihuahuas you feeding
chihuahuas our good buddy has one and no
i'm not kick [ __ ] rocks those things
are scrappy
they really got
take a valium and relax watch the ball
game these things are [ __ ] on edge if
they don't like you they let you know
yeah
a little kiwi head get the [ __ ] outta
here
they're so cute um
but uh
she was saying and it's been in my
[ __ ] head she was saying uh they had
them once in like the 90s or something
because the neighbor's house or
something did construction and that like
riled them up to yeah it displaces them
so what'd she say about it she was
laying in bed and ran across her [ __ ]
face
she was like she was like i almost moved
she was like it was like i got up in the
middle of the night it was like that's
it everybody up we're [ __ ] no no one
sleeps
yeah i'm like yo [ __ ] that dude imagine
a mouse so last night dude i like that
that was [ __ ] one eye open one eye
willy
sleeping with my eyes dude
how the [ __ ] they get up there you sleep
in the oven
i'm in the fridge in the bathtub like
[ __ ]
will smith and i am like
i was wondering where you were going
with that
here about you and your mother-in-law
having a spritzer
oh a couple april spritzes is that what
they're doing over there
they've been doing what i know so when i
get over there i don't think a jerk off
yeah
aperol spritz
and you start off with that if you go
out to dinner you do a spritz and then
you switch to what wine or beer for the
founders
[Laughter]
these guys got buds
i mean we'll also talk you know i'll
start with the apparel spritz and then
bring me a guinness every two minutes
you do the apparel spritz clatt you
can't go wrong what's an apple flavor
liqueur
no aperol not only what's in it it's
aperol oh it's like any cherries
i like a cherry no orange wedge
at you yeah um how's the fruit over
there
is it different
what
what do you mean it's a different no
it's [ __ ] fruit you dumb the [ __ ] was
that i was reading what what apparel is
like it put me on hold
um an april spritz is
uh certain aperitif and and northeast
in northeast italy
prosecco april and soda water prosecc oh
my god that's nice that's so good dude
that's classy
i mean what kind what does what is the
flavor though
i think it is apple
could be makes sense
that's what i want to say
italian bitters bitters
uh i thought it was apple bitters
whatever who do you know yeah yeah i
don't like that [ __ ] you told me about
the [ __ ] miller high life
yeah miller high life's going under
that's [ __ ] bonko's yeah so we gotta
do like a send-off for maybe the
patriots we gotta send off we gotta
fight what are you talking about we
gotta take it to the [ __ ] street it's
like there's no way they're doing that
it's no the 11 brands it's like steel
reserve
who owns this miller uh who is it coors
something coors called chorus company
but it's somebody in chords it's like in
bev and coors okay whatever um yeah to
focus on more like uh high quality craft
beers and stuff that's [ __ ] stupid
man mgd or [ __ ] miller high life is a
[ __ ] classy beer no it's not you
serve them ice cold they are listen this
is 32 33 32.5
this is [ __ ] i don't know how you
forget this all the time just because
it's it is good it's not classy no
no it's not clear yeah yeah um but we
can wrap this up it's popular though how
about that
yeah i love your sales have to be good
sure i think i bet you they just threw
that in there for marketing purposes
that's the one that uh we're going to
save mgd yeah
miller highlight like you're saying mgd
they don't do that anymore they miller
genuine draft
that stuff was if that shit's still out
there that was liquid gold if that
shit's still out there and you're
[ __ ] and you're getting rid of miller
high life i'll [ __ ] i'll lose it
mgd beer is that still around cut that
[ __ ]
steal reserve i get yeah get rid of that
[ __ ] crap
that's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
but high life
what
what yeah uh are you kidding me what are
we doing
yeah i don't know it's probably not that
many more like ads you know from from a
mark from a business standpoint i
disagree with that i i think that's a
new year i don't even say anything
you're gonna say that more people are
drinking nicer beer i think across the
country they're not they're not [ __ ]
getting cases of [ __ ] uh
you know [ __ ] highbrow micro brews
they're getting [ __ ] hot microbrews
different than a [ __ ]
a lagunitas or a [ __ ] that's not a
microbrew sure you know what i mean or
like hey give me something and they're
also looking for like hey in 10 years if
sales are dropping every year of this
for the past five years
in ten years
it's going to be we're already you got
to get a headache [ __ ] white claw oh
of course yeah that's another thing i
want to shift to seltzer's
god you should try the celsius i've had
the celsius celsius are good they're
great yeah they're getting [ __ ] up
as much as the next cultures dude you do
like blinky in the last summer the hot
sun they're standing plus that's malt
liquor something oh it's bad no it's
almo it's bad
good
you're just giving it so you say you you
want to focus on higher brow stuff but
not really you really want to focus on
cheaper [ __ ] to [ __ ] force down
people's throats
malt liquor are you upset at me do you
think i'm on the did i making this
decision i don't know what you were
doing over there you could have cut this
[ __ ] deal in some board room and hot
sure all i know
sure uh but yeah let's wrap it up gang
we love you we appreciate your patience
also we never even mentioned toby's not
here toby's not here so uh
let's hope this is recording yeah let's
hope this is recording t-bones on a
flight coming back from t-bone got
t-bone's flight got delayed but it was
carolina we needed it uh we needed to
record so yeah yeah good stuff we love
you see you next week
peace